dans l'atelier de france miniature le
château de versailles va se faire
refaire une beauté
son toit on a bien besoin ici on a un
jeu une simple et puis là si on passe la
main ça fait des vagues chaque hiver et
des maquettes ont droit à un peu de
nettoyage et pour certaines comme la
bâtisse du roi soleil
une restauration complète mine de rien
les rails dans leurs 28 ème année et
elle souffre comme nous des années qui
passent
globalement oui c'est la restauration la
réfection et l'entretien de façon à ce
que elle doit le plus longtemps possible
il présente bien le maquettiste
retravaille les bâtiments de la toiture
aux petites sculptures dont chacune a
son propre moule importants chantiers en
cours la création de 250 orangé pour le
parc du château
il faut aussi qu'on trouve des matériaux
qui soit durable dans le temps on a
essayé pas mal de choses notamment les
fleurs artificielles mais ça ça vieillit
pas très bien assez rapidement ça ça
cuit au soleil et les meilleurs
résultats sont obtenus avec le gazon
artificiel qui est un de nos alliés sur
le parc plus loin les maquettes passe
par l'atelier couleurs le peintre
décorateur reprend minutieusement le
toit de l'abbaye saint antoine
je pose d'abord le vert ensuite je veux
poser le rouge en bande large et ensuite
le noir va s'appuyer sur le rouge
ce qu'il faut c'est que les quatre
bandes est à peu près la même épaisseur
et qu'elles soient bien dirigées les
maquettes sont rénovées mais doivent
conserver un aspect vieilli par le temps
comme leur modèle d'origine plus qu'un
travail de couleur c'est un travail de
matière pour cela il faut jouer avec
toutes sortes ingrédients magiques
conservés dans des bocaux
par exemple ça c'est de la poudre de
briques qu'on colle avec de la peinture
voyez
on commence avec la peinture ça permet
d'avoir des bons effets sur les toitures
si vous avez une poudre de mika
certaines toitures ont des brillances
comme ça donc on en met un petit peu on
colle dans la peinture les 117 maquette
du parc sont entre de bonnes mains
le château de versailles peut de nouveau
à arborer ses dorures et à côté de lui
sa principale concurrente aussi retrouve
une nouvelle jeunesse trop lourde à
déplacer la dame de fer de 10 mètres à
son propre échafaudages et ne connaît
pas l'atelier reine des monuments de
france sont ces restaurateurs qui
viennent à elle